[Music]
in not-so-sweet news oh so maybe if I
save me Superman
yeah a 25 year old woman faces probation
after throwing a fit because her boba
drink wasn't sweet oh I sleep this I
feel bad for anyone that dates this
[ __ ] dude mm-hmm
I'm or should I get my like quarter
suite now too sweet on you man people
nowadays when they want something sweet
they want to rot your [ __ ] teeth and
because that's like the standard they're
like this isn't sweet I know this is
normal sweet what you eat is [ __ ]
disgusting
remember the coca-cola in France it was
pretty good [ __ ] was so good I liked
that Mexican [ __ ] though I'm actually
gonna cook biscuits just like that and
you just have a whole bunch of ice with
it do people complain about your ice
cream being not sweet enough no I mean
that I doubt that it's like one or two
that come in but then you look at their
yelps and they like places with four
cookies so it makes sense like for their
palate yeah it's not gonna be sweet
enough but that's like one out of like
two hundred no [ __ ] love just the one
good thing that came out of this
friendship you and me Oh strips and
swirls oh yo I'll tell you this though
I'm your number one fan now I don't know
what is gonna go up but we're doing a
back-to-school special we're gonna have
three cereal flavors Cinnamon Toast
Crunch is my strawberry cinnamon toast
crunch oh wait I don't think kids cereal
anymore dude really they don't like us
kids don't buy them that [ __ ] they try
to make them all healthy I think like
cereals like it's unhealthy I just feel
like parents today are buying their kids
those [ __ ] granola ass cereals that
have no sugar in it I didn't know that
other cereals besides frosted flakes
flakes existed until I was like
14 I'm SATs all my family I 5 I never
really thought about it
I've never really thought about it
because um for some reason my Vita me
sass family only bought frosted flakes
you never went to your friend's house
and rated their [ __ ] I wasn't allowed to
oh yeah and then I grew up and I learned
what Cinnamon Toast Crunch was and it
was the best thing that's ever happened
to me oh man I'm so excited
we had a flamin hot cheeto saucer - it's
funny cuz you know we were the first to
do that [ __ ] everybody's doing it now
I saw it like a three other places but
how would they even know what it tastes
like you know what the [ __ ] they doing
baby is a [ __ ] god I love that man so
much people copy the buttered corn what
we talking about this girl this Oh Bobo
right right let's talk about this [ __ ]
real quick
so this [ __ ] it's not I hate her her
name is tiara 25 years old already a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass named Sydney Australia
Yara isn't that like the yeah so she
went to go get boba at this place called
gunshots Gong cha and Gong cha cha yeah
so she went she got her boba she asked
the staff if they can add more sweetener
to her teeth and so they agreed but they
have like a limit on how much they can
put in yes it's like after after after
like you put so much it's like what do
you want just [ __ ] corn syrup all
sugar [ __ ] ain't free yeah do you just
want all sweetener yeah so then
apparently once they told you like oh
you know we can't give you any more
there's limit here
that's when she just flipped her [ __ ]
and she literally flipped her [ __ ]
because that's when there was a cake
nearby that was for an employee that
worked at that place like a 120 dollar
cake
she just flips the cake she was so angry
just buying the cake if a [ __ ] flipped
my cake I would smash my [ __ ]
knuckles into her nose so fast I love to
see that like $120 cake and she flipped
it it was been my boom all the way and
everybody would have been like well
deserved I will get that [ __ ] like
this I will go down the rapper buy the
[ __ ] there was a video like that was
the best video ever it's not as high
school football bleachers so the girl
that was picking on the girls sitting in
the lower one right there was standing
right and she dumped water in the lower
one to lower when grabbed her ankles and
flipped her that she was beautiful
amazing rapper by the ankles what the
[ __ ] dude that's a lot of fondant
probably what they called it a bikini
cake it wasn't like the body the torso
of the penis I have no idea they don't
have a photo but $120 oh you know what
though like sugar is an addictive yeah
[ __ ] chemical that isn't regulated a
hundred percent and we're seeing now the
effects of it it's some crackhead ass
behavior or something [ __ ]
yeah tattoo so she was with this guy
meme baby that's not even a real name f
ey ez yes
hey why she was amazed yes
so she was with that dude and as soon as
she started flipping her [ __ ] he joined
in and said what are we doing here and
[ __ ] whatever just follow along looks
like a party what he ends up doing is he
started pulling appliances from the
counters the mugs that they had Oh
Hartigan drugs and drugs like he's
probably trying to press her like oh
[ __ ] okay if I do this she'll probably
bang me
yeah well another saying like he
destroyed property with the value
exceeding two thousand dollars hey I'll
see now that is a guy that's easy
now you could literally beat the [ __ ]
face stop him dude that's true why was
it fair a freaking fool masterwork maybe
with a kung-fu master right when he
throws the monkey catches it with his
foot that's embarrassing dude someone
has to deal with this [ __ ] every
[ __ ] day someone can access marry
this [ __ ] and have kids with her I
would like to pin her to the floor and
just punch like her right shoulder blade
so it just hurts you can't beat you so
now she's on a six-month good behavior
bond [ __ ] that which is an order of the
court that requires you to be a good
behavior for a specified period of
amount it's like taking a current
management classes and she has to pay
back one of that grandpa's conditions
that you will have to obey during the
term of good behavior bond to maximum
duration is literally hate can you not
be a [ __ ] like the exactly just
stopping you in a [ __ ] for six months
and a half to that go right back
what about her boyfriend like don't they
have to pay fines or in all that stuff
yeah so he's facing charges for the two
thousand dollars good I think that she
has to be forced to drink unsweetened
tea three times a day I should be forced
to drink the whole bottle of corn syrup
sweetener and see what happens to like
we are pellets are very subtle
dialed down you're one of those [ __ ]
Yelp [ __ ] dude you know everything
you [ __ ] [ __ ] eight infested
[ __ ] yelping for the wrong reason dude
why'd you get offended I was like no I
was like Oh aggressive you know y'all
purchase that's [ __ ] they just wake up
and not so today I woke up and I was
like I needed some sweet nobody gives a
[ __ ] about your diary [ __ ] talk about
the food ho she's the one that's like
excuse me manager I hope you [ __ ] get
run over
I mean you live yeah yeah you know what
I would do if I had that logo shop is I
would have charged them for an extra cup
of simple syrup mm-hmm but I want to
charge like five bucks mm-hmm to make
sure they know yo we don't do this and
I'm gonna overcharge your ass Jackie
about that make my money yeah I mean why
didn't they do they could have avoided
all that [ __ ] by discharging her extra
is it because [ __ ] like that are not
used to people saying no to them like
their parents spoil the [ __ ] out of them
and [ __ ] and in the real world I think
she's severely addicted to sugar and it
triggers something in her so it's like a
crackhead that can't get their crap
[ __ ] is fire as to or Phase II or what
it is is their picture of things you
know I think what they should do in all
these boba stores is you know how like
airplanes have these secret air marshals
right all the Bulbasaur's
should have a secret kung-fu Marshall
and he's like you know the protector or
she can be like making vulva and you
don't know who it is but when there's
some kind of [ __ ] angry boba thing
happening they pop out of the [ __ ]
counter and start [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
they didn't have that come through air
marshal that's why like throw bulb at
you and like breakneck speeds it's so
meaner to like you would never expect
this to happen in a place unless you
customized sweetness yeah when you when
you can customize this pickles really
[ __ ] sweet so how sweet this you want
yeah I just imagine this [ __ ] on her
everyday life just being a [ __ ] about
everything god see people I [ __ ] hate
people like that dude what would you
have done if you were they employees and
yelling people you know I do like that
one [ __ ] at the
man or the owner of that thing oh I wish
you destroyed more [ __ ] pay for all
of it dude dumpster upon her [ __ ] you
that's the reason why I actually want to
be a business owner in like a restaurant
business or whatever just so I can I
feel like people that are shitty people
go into businesses and treat people like
[ __ ] cuz they know they have to be nice
to them hmm
so they know the workers aren't gonna be
a [ __ ] like you know that's why so
they're it's almost like someone who
picks on defenseless and weak people to
get a little ego boost
that's like cops yeah owning a business
like that with customer service I am
living I'm like waiting just for that
one day when someone says I want to
speak to your manager and all I have to
say is when you have a business to its
site that type of person that comes very
and very rarely it's like probably three
percent you know I mean and it leaves
that's why you act like teach also like
employees to honestly like you have to
make that person walk away happy because
at the end of the day like that person's
not going to affect your life in the
future but it affects the business so
that person causes a scene and they act
stupid they could leave a bad review
they could do all the stuff but you
can't control it makes you look bad too
because if they leave a bad review they
don't know context they don't know what
that person did that so you just always
make the customer happy you try to do
your best
yeah I read a review for your place but
like I said that's like one person out
of how many you know yeah that's not
once in a lifetime but sometimes people
complain cuz they want free [ __ ] yeah
they trick the system yeah and those
people too you just you just got a deal
with it or you just tell them next time
like hey like we had you know certain
customers that came in and there's like
this one person left this is a bad
review it got taken down but the guy
came in and he kept on asking for free
[ __ ] and so he was like oh this isn't
what we ordered this isn't what I
ordered you know it's like come on bro
but at the end of the day it's like hey
the tickets here but the next time you
do this we're not gonna give it to you
unless of lesson left there's a bad
review that got taken down but there are
people like that but I can't let that
negative person affect the rest of our
good customers right so I want to make a
restaurant where it's like life
threatening you
you're you're out there great pitch
right now you know the sign that that
it's like this owner will SH is armed
and we'll shoot mm-hmm I'll have that in
the front and then I'll have beware
attack dogs right so then so it's kind
of like the restaurant is bomb food it's
really really good so like when you get
there it's like so [ __ ] good that
you're willing to risk your life but
I'll find some way where like I'll make
it seem like they're trespassing or
trying to rob us or something so if
someone does piss us off we could [ __ ]
them up mm so it's like the extreme
version of The Soup Nazi from Seinfeld
yeah looks like I'll be at the register
and in like some guys being a [ __ ]
dick I could grab him by the collar and
slam their head over and over the
restaurant of death when I was 18 and
really amateur and working the
restaurant history with people like that
were really douche bags and [ __ ] out
happily give him that simple syrup but
it's no simple syrup would be like some
apple cider vinegar there's one [ __ ]
that I used to work in a front desk in
the hotel she was the one she came in 11
o'clock maybe 11:30 she's like where's
the breakfast I'm like I need a tenant
she started bitching like I paid good
money I'm like [ __ ] you're in a Best
Western made good money I want my
breakfast why is it closed I'm like
because it's half an hour to lunch time
and she complained and complain and like
she was one of those people I want a
free [ __ ] eventually she got free [ __ ]
from my manager one day or one time she
came up or she came down she's like no
matter what button I hit on the vending
machine it just all gave me diet and I
was just like in my mind I was like god
I wish I just maybe the machines telling
you something I hope you guys enjoy this
video for more please subscribe to our
Channel and you can check out the last
video right here
[Music]